I can still appreciate the fact that  every time we fly we are getting access  to A View to a a physical perspective  that nearly all human beings on Earth  who've ever lived have never had access  to thousands of generations came and  went without without any one of them  ever seeing the Earth from more than a  few hundred feet up and most of them  there was never more than like eight or  nine feet up in there if that and we're  able to see from 35 000 feet and you  want to keep the shade down  we have this view of the earth that no  almost no one's ever been able to see  and you want to you don't you didn't  want to look at it do you go to the  Grand Canyon just keep your back turned  to it the entire time  you probably do because that's what  people do now they give their back turns  they can take selfies so they experience  the Grand Canyon through the phone  behind them